[Applaudissements]
il
oh
sur le lac léman chaque matin à l'aube
martin et son beau-frère guillon un
rituel
il ya des fers à karim lever leurs 800
mètres de filets de pêche tient bon vous
voir ça va être magnifique dans cinq
minutes plus pour ça ça va valoir le
coup de venir jusque là ces roseaux ce
matin gbagbo martin est une figure du
lac léman
elle a été la première femme pêcheurs ya
trente ans je suis devenu pêcheuses
parce que mon père était pêcheur et puis
un bon jour m'a dit tiens si toi tu veux
faire pêcheurs boudiba et banco on va
essayer puis surtout c'est depuis mes 12
12 13 ans j'allais l'aider à lever les
nas l'été allait lever un peu les filets
comme ça mais juste font plaisir et puis
du coup ben voilà c'est pas marrant tous
les jours c'est pas voilà mais enfin moi
de mon point de vue oui on est
privilégié
moi j'ai décidé que je disais pêcheurs
le jour et je reste la nuit c'est plus
marrant voilà la c'est la dèche
ce matin c'est catastrophique
le nombre de poissons la peine d'une
caisse à il nous reste deux finales vais
donc a priori c'est pas super en en a'
pauvre 150 euros peut-être je n'aime pas
à 2 2 la wii martine elle mange aussi ça
fait un mois et demi deux mois que c'est
vraiment pas gagné faut il croire toute
façon si vous y croyez pas en fait pas
ce métier comme ça c'est vite vu
[Applaudissements]
ce qui fait tenir martine c'est la
beauté du lac
y'a pas de mots pour expliquer le lac
c'est la sérénité la beauté on se lasse
jamais de paysages comme ça ou c'est la
fête
on est né ici et j'aime mon là toute
façon j'habiterai nulle part ailleurs
qu'ici ça c'est couru d'avancé
un petit calment
[Musique]
formé il ya quinze minant par les
glaciers alpins le léman est le plus
grand lac d'europe occidentale long de
73 km d'un côté la france de l'autre la
suisse il fascine autant par sa faune
que par la variété des paysages eaux
cristallines montagne on vignes classées
au patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
vous avez pas froisser toulon ouais on
est juste bien pour corinne le léman
c'est une histoire de famille
patron d'un restaurant de poissons sur
les rives françaises une avec un pot de
crème est jeune mais c'est bien ça elle
nous fera découvrir la gastronomie du
lac des recettes transmises depuis trois
générations
du côté suisse
une drôle d'embarcation c'est le bateau
de gilbert le chasseur d'épaves du lac
les abîmes du lac cache de nombreux
vestiges sous marins et aujourd'hui
encore il continue en découvrir bon bah
je suis content on la trouvait le fils
françois et manon à eux ne connaissent
encore rien du léman mais ils ont décidé
de changer de vie ils quittent leur
bretagne natale pour s'installer au bord
du lac
seule difficulté ils ont moins de deux
semaines pour trouver un logement
tant qu'on a pas les que l'aura toujours
le petit stress et s'installer sur les
rives du lac relève du parcours du
combattant
c'est ici à lugrin sur la rive française
que martin a grandi c'est aussi là
qu'elle a ouvert sa pêcherie avec guy la
pêche du jour est mauvaise
une vingtaine de kilos seulement au lieu
de 80 en moyenne les eaux froides du
léman regorge de truites perches
brochets ou lot mais aussi la féra un
poisson des profondeurs
la vedette du lac léman ça c'est la
paire away corégones en est le nom
scientifique
ja c'est un poisson que les gras mais
pas trop coûteux et donc on peut le
visiter pour en manger toute la semaine
tu mangeras jamais même l'a jamais
martin a dû se faire une place parmi les
150 pêcheurs du lac
pourtant lorsqu'elle a commencé elle
n'était pas vraiment la bienvenue
reste une révolution dans le monde de la
pêche
c'est un milieu est macho mais ne se
laisse pas faire non plus donc les
autres pêcheurs ont appris à la
connaître aussi évaluer avait du poids
soit comment y en a beaucoup qui
attendaient de voir combien de temps je
les tenir en fait c'est surtout ça
trente ans plus tard martin est toujours
là il y a dix ans elle s'est associée
avec guy le mari de sa soeur et moi j'ai
deux indiquant même les gens étaient
très surpris a croisé martine quelque
part avec son mari way en plus gêné de
me croiser le coup d'après dès demain
matin 3 heures
les deux pêcheurs retourneront sur l'eau
pour lever leurs filets en espérant que
le lac soit plus généreux
au dessus de la pêcherie la voisine se
réveille doucement
françoise 75 ans et la mère de martin
salue les gamins
houas le matin je me lève je dis bonjour
aux oiseaux je dis bonjour au lac jeudi
chalut françoise a toujours vécu au bord
du lac
ah les beaux bébés aller et ce qu'elle
aime par dessus tout ce sont ces petits
habitants de new kick ça mord pas c'est
une idée préconçue st c'est les gens
disent que ça mon nom ça passe parce
qu'ils ont des petits ya trois comme
animaux ici il ya des grèbes huppés avec
une petite jupe rouge dessus il ya des
héros vous avez dû en voir mais regardez
là bas la bayanne à il ya des canards
comme ça à colbert des colverts si vous
avez les mouettes avec le bec très très
rouge n'est pas très très rouge et vous
avez le goéland il est énorme
il a fait fuir d'ailleurs toutes nos
petites mouettes qu'on avait le lac est
un théâtre à lui tout seul le lac me
régénère me nettoie mon lev mais ce qui
me redonne la joie le mât grand beau
temps
comment vous voyez j'écoutais la météo
elle elle a écouté la météo et moi je
regardais la non mais c'est grand beau
demain non normalement quand on voit la
suisse très près ces signes de mauvais
temps ça c'est toute mon enfance un
martin j'ai su nager avant de savoir
marcher ou qu'est-ce que je l'avais dit
je les lanciers à l'eau non quand
j'étais pas tu balances et papa ah oui
c'est la paire toi qui nous allons c'est
au lac avant de savoir nager marché mais
vous savez ici chez la vie rêvée
c'est le rêve éveillé dans trois
semaines
la famille délivre un événement le
mariage de la fille de martine
[Applaudissements]
cette virée v françois et manon ont
traversé la france pour la trouver ces
bretons viennent tout juste de poser
leurs valises dans la région le fils
regarde on est vraiment juste à côté en
gâtant punaise la vue tu as vu le doute
tout cas me manon 23 ans est infirmière
en cdd aux hôpitaux du léman
françois 25 ans est en période d'essai
pour un cdi de maître d'hôtel à evian
tout semble leur sourire
un détail près
à cause d'un départ un peu mouvementée
ils occupent pour le moment un logement
temporaire à une trentaine de kilomètres
du lac abondance en haute savoie
c'est au studio qu'on a trouvé en
précipiter ces petits quand même c'est
trop petit pour du long terme
ah ouais on appris par des pieds parce
qu'il y avait que ça va croiser les
doigts de pouvoir trouver un moment
donné de partout en bretagne françois et
manon doivent trouver un autre logement
rapidement dans deux semaines leur
studio sera loué à des vacanciers
on se fait hausse mais là le jeune
couple a déjà démarché une douzaine
d'agents ce sans succès
le marché immobilier autour du lac est
très concurrentiel et leur situation
professionnelle n'inspire pas confiance
aux propriétaires c'est vrai qu'en font
les urgences soit c'est mon cas qui est
jean paul besset mais c'est pas terminée
donc c'est problématique soit ses
mannequins en chaîne des cdd du coup ça
passe pas illustration dès le premier
coup de fil
oui bonjour madame je me paraît nous
appeler ce que j'ai vu un bien sur votre
site qui était proposée en location et
potentiellement nous étions intéressés
alors là tu moi je suis en cdi enfin
veuve 17 cd à l'hôtel hermitage à evian
est mon ami là elle a commencé aux
hôpitaux du léman
actuellement elle enchaîne cdd sur cdd
mais c'est en vue d'une titularisation
par la suite d'accords la journée madame
avoir massivement comme d'habitude un
sans surprise en six ans maintenant on
connaît le discours
donc c'est vrai que les portes et siame
trouver un logement n'est pas le seul
défi que doit relever le jeune couple
aujourd'hui françois prend ses fonctions
de maître d'hôtel dans l'un des
établissements les plus réputés du léman
à evian-les-bains l'ermitage un hôtel 4
étoiles domine un magnifique parc
naturel surplombant le lac bon casse et
intimidé un petit peu d'appréhension
dans le musée dans la mesure pardon
c'est une belle maison
donc voilà on va voir ce que ça va
donner croisons les doigts
le jeune homme doit absolument réussir
sa période d'essai bonjour madame
sans ce travail trouver un logement sera
impossible
[Musique]
pour lui présenter cet hôtel créé au
début des années 1900 et récemment
rénové c'est alberto son manager qui
l'accueille entre deux chambres vue
magnifique sur le lac leman d'accord
comme vous pouvez voir c'est vraiment
très cosy hôtels ça que la vie est
vraiment vraiment juif midi françois
prend son service pour la toute première
fois à première-- premier client de mon
premier service
tu peux l'appréhension mais comptant
pourtant commencé ma distinction discret
habituel longueur si le client est
discret room service
l'entrée de françois l'étain peu moins
d'effectifs la porte après ça va venir
je vais prendre les bons angles là
dessus 19h30 au restaurant de l'hôtel
les choses sérieuses commencent pour le
jeune homme son travail consiste à
accueillir et placer les clients avant
de prendre les commandes
86 hockey 100 ch sous l'oeil de ses
collègues françois n'a pas le droit à
l'erreur même savourer la vue sur le lac
léman ce soir il doit faire face à tout
type d'imprévu
comme la météo alors madame la carte du
restaurant saas couvrant un petit peu
dommage mais une si belle vue regardez
comme c'est magnifique
voyez que ça va durer elle fait de la
manutention à françois un petit peu ça
fait partie des le changement de
programme de dernière minute on ne
serais-je bien passé de cette animation
là mais bon voilà déjà depuis zagreb
pour vous françois pas l'habitude de ces
de ces événements au moins il fait
toujours beau presque dans la fiche
connais pas je vais prouver si c'est là
qu'il faut garder son calme qu'il faut
rester assez facile face à une absence
ou à me faire sans une maison mais ça
sent mauvais vis-à-vis du client pas
embêtés vous avez vu les clients ne le
prennent pas mal il faut les accompagner
simplement il puis tout va bien se
passer
ok ça marche évitez les autres c'était
bien
mauvaise habitude pour le hockey il ya
des termes il ya des thermes
que j'ai l'habitude de dire sont pas les
termes forcément péjoratif mais qu'il
faut pas qu'il faut éviter
pour éviter justement ce côté un peu
familiers ou un peu brasserie bistrot
qui va pas avec le positionnement de
l'établissement et m'ont dit du coup
perdu un quasi ça se passe bien mais à
gré quelques petites options de dialogue
nous un petit peu oui c'est surtout le
lancement après sa roue tout seul mais
entre les arrivées à plus de commandes
reste un petit peu compliqué pour le
lancement mais ça va merci albert trop
seul risque pour le moment françois
encore intimidés par les lieux un peu de
mal pour la prise de commandes
oui on peut faire plein de chasse en
rouge est si vous voulez un sens rouge
et donc finalement on arrive un quasi
vous enlevez le pavé de thon 100 ans
choix je remets le quasi on va y arriver
on va y arriver et une patience et 200
rouge et je crois que cette fois ci tous
les sens et des gains attendus
oui bien sûr merci messieurs chef d'ata
que je ne vous en voyez pour le monsieur
qui a pris le bellota il est allergique
mortel au vinaigre
s'il y avait lieu de vinexpo mais oui
voilà une dégustation
est-ce que je ne m'inquiète pas après
des débuts hésitants
ces délicieuses que je mangeais toi
françois semble enfin trouver ses
marques
là c'est la tension qui attend
tranquillement
on doit ce travail est plutôt très
agréable ce soit avec mes subordonnés ou
mes supérieurs
ce que du positif ce soir françois
finalement été à la hauteur mais pour
que son aventure au bord du léman
continue il lui faut absolument trouver
un logement
et vite
allez-y le dossier de demande de
location
merci à remplir donc pour monsieur et
madame on est au dessus d'eux n'est pas
vrai qu'on va peut-être découvrir
aujourd'hui
de l'autre côté du lac la rive suisse
[Applaudissements]
c'est dans le port de lausanne
que se cache le gardien des secrets du
léman gilbert payet 73 ans est chasseur
d'épaves gilbert n'est pas au premier
abord une personne très loquace mais sur
les épaves du léman il est intarissable
il en a découvert des dizaines grâce à
un robot unique construit de ses propres
mains
on voit ici la caméra qui est derrière
son hublot avec un couvercle automatique
à travers une loupe la caméra voit une
boussole ce qui permet de savoir dans
quelle direction regarde le robot côte
il est 100 200 ou 300 mètres en dessous
du bateau
pierre et son capitaine depuis 50 ans et
il assiste dans la plupart de ses
recherches pour moment temps va bien peu
devant mais ça peut toujours changer
aujourd'hui il espère ajouter un nouveau
trophée à leur tableau de chasse
au fil des années gilbert a localisé
plus de 60 épaves objets insolites comme
d'anciens wagons ou des restes de
bateaux notamment celle du rhône sa plus
importante découverte ce bateau à vapeur
de 43 mètres datant de la belle époque
et prôner en 1883 par une autre
embarcation
il transportait des marchandises du
bétail et 25 passagers plus de la moitié
a péri quand le bateau a coulé à plus de
300 mètres gilbert cherche cette fois un
petit bateau repéré il ya 20 ans par un
sous-marin
il serait à 130 mètres de fond on est au
dessus de quelque chose une épave qu'on
va peut-être découvrir aujourd'hui il
s'agit de l'étrange d'une petite barque
qui dépasse de la boue on va les voir ce
qu'il reste
on va s'assurer comme un image sur son
bateau gilbert a quasiment tout fabriqué
lui-même
non j'avais depuis le poste de pilotage
descendre jusqu'à voir le fond on ne
sait pas ce qu'il y a on sait pas ce
qu'on va voir
il y as forcément d'adrénaline alors ça
c'est la partie pénible quand il faut
chercher quelque chose qui est pas très
grand on arrive sur le point après 30
minutes de fouilles la patience de
gilbert paye enfin
la voilà ce qui reste bon ben je suis
content on l'a trouvé on voit bien
l'avant qui s'est disloqué il ya les
deux parois une ici et puis on voit
aussi un peu de cordages il ya une rame
et puis le plus intéressant c'est son
grappin
quand on cherche quelque chose et qu'on
trouve quoi que ce soit c'est toujours
une réussite en soi
et puis là-bas c'est quand même quelque
chose d'historique historique car
l'épave remontrer au 19e siècle mais
pour le moment
l'explorateur n'en sait pas plus gilbert
va commencer la deuxième phase de
recherches et peut-être découvrir enfin
l'histoire de ce bateau
à nyon sur la côte suisse au musée du
léman
ici tout le monde connaît gilbert payet
il est reçu par le conservateur du musée
c'est là parmi les trésors lacustre que
le chasseur d'épaves va tenter d'en
savoir plus sur sa découverte de bach
pointu aux deux bouts de poke didier
documentaliste pense avoir trouvé
l'origine du bateau ce serait une no une
barque de pêcheur utilisé avant la
seconde guerre mondiale celui ci il y
avait des bateaux de ce type dans tous
les ports
donc c'est probablement un de ses bâtons
que j'ai fait naufrage et tu as trouvé
ces embarcations elles ont été utilisées
par des gens qui travaillaient au bord
du léman qui allait pêcher avec qui
transportait des choses mais à mon avis
ça me paraît impossible d'avoir plus
d'indications à ce stade il serait trop
coûteux de remonter l'épave pour
l'examiner
l'ancienne marque gardera donc sa part
de mystère
du côté français à margencel près de
thonon les bains
c'est le début de saison au restaurant
chez jules une institution gastronomique
du léman à l'est corinne la patronne ne
commet jamais sa journée sans saluer
tous ces employés ça lui les jeunes à
base est là partout yannick et le chef
cuisinier et ce n'est pas un employé
comme les autres c'est yannick c'est mon
fils c'est mon deuxième
voilà
1 et 5 ici on travaille en famille
tracy la pâtissière et la belle-fille de
corinne bonjour la cuisine et via
georgette sa mère sa maman
pas bien ouais tu as entre oman avec des
écrevisses du lac ya peu au bord du lac
il faut vraiment de la vraie vie ce qu
avec des vrais écrevisses du lac ça
c'est clair
phi phi est le père de corinne et avec
ludo un autre fils de la patronne ce
sont eux qui pêchent les fameuses
écrevisses et la majorité des poissons
cuisinés dans le restaurant on a
toujours vécu tous ensemble toutes les
générations
quand j'étais enfant il y avait mes
grands parents ont donc ma tente
maintenant ben yahia encore mes parents
il ya mes enfants qui sont la russie aux
natures vécu comme ça
le restaurant est dans la famille depuis
les recettes transmises de génération en
génération et l'emplacement ont fait de
ce restaurant de poisson un lieu
incontournable du léman il peut
accueillir jusqu'à 400 personnes
là c'est notre terrasse donc voilà 200
personnes quand ça veut sourire voilà
sera pas aujourd'hui
et puis on a 200 places aussi à
l'intérieur
en quoi votre restaurant est différent
des autres ici c'est ça le lac la vue
mais c'était merci pépé
merci c'est mon arrière grand père qui a
acheté ici j'ai acheté le site
voilà alors je peux vous proposer midi
lors du premier service et où la petite
table ronde au fond de deux côtés le
restaurant est loin d'afficher complet
bonjour monsieur monsieur on a juste un
groupe de 24 aujourd'hui
et puis à côté on verra aujourd'hui fait
pas beau habituellement le mercredi on
est fermé donc là on avait
exceptionnellement ce qu'on avait ce
groupe
donc du coup ça risque d'être une
journée un peu tranquille en appétit
savard et tout ce qu'il faut vous avez
toutes les deux la vue comme ça c'est
bien là à les gens lèvent tout le reste
merci et vous avez l'habitude de bien
ici mais jusqu'au harcèlement super
agréable des recettes traditionnelles de
poissons du lac
il y en a pour tous les goûts free
sauter ni jeter ou à la plancha balle
aux projets mais la note 500 d'une
rivière dans le lac léman en bout mais
mes 4 est il depuis peu et yannick
lejeune chef apporte sa touche
personnelle à certaines spécialités
on se modernisant peut on les cuit
maintenant on va se taper ratures c'est
à dire qu'on les agresse pas du tout on
récupère donc expliquer aux bons à
température assez basse
on peut la chair est moelleux
ici le mot d'ordre est la bonne ambiance
la recette fonctionne ça va bonnabaud
tient même en ce début de saison
le restaurant se remplit avec une
clientèle variée de l'ouvrier aux chefs
d'entreprises françaises et étrangères
ces producteurs de thé viennent tout
droit de l'himalaya leurs clients
français a tenu à ce qu'il découvre ce
restaurant typique
alors vous avez le carpaccio de ferrat
la féra fumée la féra conflit talus de
livres basilique le tartare de ferrat et
les rillettes de ferrat ici vous avez la
mousse de fer au beurre blanc qu elle
avait un fils et deux de brochet en
grave là avec un petit jeu au curry et
quelques agréments
je viens de l'himalaya de l'everest
chez nous nous avons également des
poissons de rivière cliché mais ils sont
différents les poissons d'ici sont
vraiment délicieux 15h fin du service
l'heure des comptes va mieux que ce
qu'on pensait franchement on a bien bien
je sais pas mais moi oui là aujourd'hui
on fait 2000 euros ce midi et une
semaine d'or saison entre 35 et 40
millions une semaine de deux grosses
saisons entre 100 et 120 dans quelques
jours corinne va accueillir un groupe de
150 personnes
le premier grand défi de sa saison
[Applaudissements]
à lugrin dans sa pêcherie hugues martin
à elle un défi quotidien démêler les sac
de noeuds de ses filets à séoul c'était
un paquet il était c'était beaucoup au
paquet ou bah oui j'ai cette passion
jusque moi là dessus je suis pas patient
ça les énerve et donc ça va beaucoup
moins vite dès qu'on s'énerve non
martinez très forts pour ça
là c'est plutôt un paquet attend bouge
pas dit à l'ats c'est bon là oui et
voilà magie magie
aujourd'hui martine tiens tu as assisté
à un événement qui a lieu chaque année à
evian les bains
mais les voilà à l'éclat choc j'aurais
déclaré les clochettes une transhumance
de brebis en plein centre ville
bonjour gagné peur et ya mangé gratos
les pépères mai mais quoi
jean-marie déplace ses brebis vers la
montagne pour qu'elle y passe l'été au
frais tant qu'il n'y a pas de la chèvre
capucine elle ouvre devant et puis les
gens qui me suivent quand ici encore 60
km à parcourir jusqu aux alpages de
là-haut les moutons on rompt une vue
imprenable sur le lac une vue dont on ne
se lasse pas martin et aujourd'hui c'est
un jour spécial pour cette mère de
famille
priscilla sa fille de 25 ans se marient
dans deux semaines théâtre up
enfin peut-être que deschamps la robe et
ça c'est sa jolie robe
y'a plus qu'à rentrer dedans voulais
j'avais raccourci le bas du jupon j'ai
rien oublié normalement mais c'est vous
qui avez fait les retouches les
retouches oui là c'est fin prêt
normalement il ya j'ai tout vérifié les
perles tout ça normalement c'est que ce
billet y'a plus qu'à ces nouveaux rêves
de princesse en plus de la robe
martin se charge de toute la décoration
du mariage qu'elle fabrique elle-même
ça s'appelait prince est parfait c'est
quand même pas commun d'avoir une mère
pêcheuses un hamac en haîti ça passe
passe et à tuchan quoi sont ils assez
mais c'est pas méchant c'est séduisant
favoris n'ont jamais mal pris mais non
maintenant moi je le ferai pas je frotte
à fraîcheur cessé après oui enfin c'est
une passion pour elle c'est une passion
et c'est beaucoup beaucoup de travail et
beaucoup investi ces fameux l'axé son
milieu et ça se passe bien mais un peu
et les poissonniers alors il est à doha
n'ont même pas poissons de a à z un
poisson d'eau douce celui le poisson de
mer
le poisson dans tous ses états martin
doit encore confectionner une dizaines
de bouquets et la décoration des tables
130 personnes sont attendues pour le
mariage
à thonon les bains
pour françois et manon le grand jour
cette aujourd'hui ils ont réussi à
décrocher une visite pour un appartement
tout près du lac
bonjour allez on y va
wake partir sophie directrice d'une
agence immobilière à accepter leurs
dossiers et leur propose un deux pièces
en rez-de-jardin 56 m² pour 670 euros
d'une cuisine aménagée
ouais donc on va pas l'électroménager à
part parce que chez moi la plaque
maintenant trop voilà avec la haute on a
eu notre intégrée avec des grosses
bagarres l'apprenti mois enfin c'est
comme ça moi c'est génial espaces la
bonne surprise c'est ce jardin privatif
grand jardin série qu'elle ça ne
m'attendais pas un grand jardin comme ça
on est à cinq minutes à pied du lac
on le voit on traverse en voilà on est à
vol d'oiseau vol d'oiseau le lac il est
à 200 m 1 validée au web sans son style
l'appartement est parfait il est
complètement dans nos critères
coup de coeur beaucoup coup de coeur on
se voit déjà dedans on imagine les meufs
on va les mettre dans les plus qu'à
croiser les doigts ça passe le dossier
de demande de location
merci si hockey voilà donc c'est une
fiche de location de l'appartement avec
le détail et leur dossier doit passer
maintenant en commission réponse dans
trois jours et leurs rêves de vie au
bord du lac léman deviendra peut-être
une réalité
[Musique]
mais trois jours plus tard toujours
aucune nouvelle
allez hop
jusqu'à ce que le téléphone sonne enfin
oui allô espace en commission oui dans
quelques instants
françois et manon vont savoir si leur
dossier a été accepté et le restaurant
de corinne allez venez avec moi va
connaître une soirée on voit
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon merci beaucoup maintes fois
j'en ai également à revoir merci
sans bien malgré la pluie
[Applaudissements]
j'analyserai concrètes dans en fait je
pense et c'est une épine qui sort du
pied on va dire ça comme ça et c'est un
jugement qui me plaît énormément et donc
passé c'est tout bon parfum c'est ouais
mais maintenant oui ça va être la
logistique du déménagement la salle est
encore une autre gymnastique le planning
à faire avant de se plonger dans son
déménagement
le jeune couple s'offre une première
sortie en amoureux dans un restaurant
voisin
bonjour chez corinne vous avez réservé
pas du tout face au lac
merci merci beaucoup merci
il était juste secoué les boues
ils sont anxieux filets de ferrer aux
champignons frais et bien c'est très
simple un mac ou même la dose de perche
total un régime est représenté
vu que mon métier et exigeante des fois
c'est un support
il est du coup au taquet sur le moindre
détail
ça c'est comme si c'est comme ça c'est
bon mais c'est faux quelques forces
avant le déménagement pour les aider la
famille de manon fera spécialement le
déplacement depuis la bretagne 17 heures
pour corinne c'est l'heure de la pause
avant le service du soir ou presque
restaurant le lycée au jour pour combien
de personnes s'il vous plaît mieux s'il
fait bon s'installer au bord du lac
d'accord et aujourd'hui le bilan à
bosser c'est parfait je suis hyper
heureuse venir voilà je pourrais pas
vivre autrement je pourrais pas vivre
sans cette entreprise les moments où
j'ai le plus l'impression d'exister là
où existe le plus c'est gros travail et
ce soir du travail
corinne ne va pas en manquer elle va
devoir gérer 400 clients
si je vous ai fait tout au bord du lac
là bas ça lui convient on est juste bien
si je lis salahi font allez venez avec
moi
le restaurant est complet six adultes et
ben nickel alors allez vous les premiers
clients s'apprête à passer une soirée
paisible au bord du lac
mais ça risque d'être plus animée que
prévu
cent quinze membres d'un club sportif du
village ont aussi réservé toutes les
années le foot de margencel fait son
assemblée générale et aimant celle où
toutes les années et cette année ils
sont particulièrement nombreux parce
qu'ils montrent une catégorie et les
filles ont gagné championnat
bref du coup ils sont le double de
l'habitude et en fait toutes les années
il se déguise lui les en jardinière rôle
c'est tous les gens du village jacques
c'est important pour nous de les avoir
et puis faire en sorte que ça se passe
bien mais bon on voudrait quand même
classe b ce bien pour les autres clients
aussi est très délicate cette fois
bonjour tout le monde
alors on va rentrer et on va passer dans
le chapiteau qui vous a fait un bar expo
vous et vous avez tous chapiteau pour
vous
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que ça va je suis désolé je
pensais pas qu'ils feraient tout ce que
voulait faire plus de bruit que vous
n'allez pas y aller mais ça va ça vous
gêne pas trop ça vous amuse savez ce que
je vous propose en finisse et votre très
tranquillement en essayant de faire
abstraction du bruit et je vous empêche
de dents
à
[Applaudissements]
en cuisine c'est le coup de feu mais pas
de quoi affoler yannick le fils de
corinne et corinne alala essais par
rapport aux deux clients ça peut gêner
les gens autour et là il faut savoir
combien de place ce soir yannick on doit
faire 250 plat sans compter qu'ils en
toi josiane balasko
ah ouais je sais que ta maison julie
julien jésus perso qu'elles sont entre
jésus et jules césar commune semble
enfin plus détendu
c'est bon là jamais les clients sont
plus que là bas c'est bon ça va oui oui
et toi et un plan on attaque des cibles
pour ces habitués il n'était pas
question d'aller faire la fête ailleurs
[Musique]
c'est le choix de l'équipe à chaque fois
parce que simplement on se retrouve au
bord du léman les monts ces lieux de
rassemblement river qu'on fasse tout
cela qu il faut rester pour toute
l'équipe
mais quelques minutes plus tard
l'essai du léman va refroidir les
ardeurs des combines
[Musique]
coût
à evian chez martine c'est le grand jour
sa fille se marie dans trois heures ça
c'est la vie au bord du lac léman
maquillage nature pourquoi je bouge mot
fanta c'est vraiment pas mon truc je
veux dire ici là la limite c'est tout si
peut-être de rouge à lèvres de temps en
temps j'ai jamais été maquillage même
quand j'étais jeune fille avec mon
métier c'est pas faisable a aussi je
pourrais prendre du truc est étanche du
maquillage et enflammé et pour finir des
fossiles
une première pour la pêcheuse mais je
vois mes cibles pour la première fois de
ma vie
[Rires]
ah ouais ça fait sympa ça paraît paix si
l'on regarde un an top
une heure plus tard martin attend le
verdict de son mari là on a nous fernand
voulais tu mets jamais pu les grands si
la place in app est chose rare mais
c'est promis non c'est bien bien
glissantes
c'est à la mairie de thonon-les-bains
que martin ne retrouve sa famille et
notamment sa nièce je suis comment ben
voilà on était gentil la voici dans
comme ça commente attal et pavel on a
dit me soigner et mais t'as juste et
vrai vous dis dans le costume de pécho
sécheresse elle est jolie
tu m'étonne c'est bien comme ça la salle
magnifique hassan et le futur gendre de
martine senior vous savez comment je te
noyer ouardi dont elle a les saillies
faire
[Applaudissements]
ac qui a nourri cia ont sentez-vous à
prendre pour époux hassan ici présents
oui hassan penchant tvo à prendre pour
époux précis viendrai ici présentes
oui bien entendu oui c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
22 heures
la state peut enfin commencer
[Musique]
hassan est vendeur dans une poissonnerie
proche du lac
un soulagement pour martine sa famille
restera soudé autour du léman
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je ne vous entends pas y'a suis là je
suis là je suis là la mariée la mariée
mois marty là ils sont sur une barque
tuer c'est une balance et nokia à celle
sur le lac léman ses sens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
martin et guy sont de retour sur le lac
3h30 l'heure de lever une nouvelle fois
leurs filets de pêche
la l'été c'est le top niveau
il fait bon show c'est royal mais encore
une fois le résultat ne semble pas
encourageants dans la pièce est toujours
vide
je tenais qui est pour une bonne année
on aimerait bien avoir une centaine de
kilos pour la première payera plus elle
bien au début du filet pour lui on est
content c'est qu'il n'y a plus d'espoir
là franchement pour l'instant c'est pas
le même coeur elle a égalé la fira qui
chante le bouille tendance en belle
forme de désespoir
non je le sais l'air qui ressort en fait
à s'échapper
oui techniquement mieux dans notre
caisse il aurait été dorloter
chouchouter nettoyer quelques minutes
plus tard la chance leur sourit enfin
arrive deux par deux en principe c'est
bon signe
t'as vu ça c'est une belle mama celles
là sont comme on aime bien c'est qu'elle
fait du poids dans la caisse ça commence
à venir
tiens bon goût les deux derniers filets
regorge de poissons
on va mieux finir qu'on a commencé hier
sa lettre cinq caisses
au total les deux pêcheurs ramènent dans
leurs caisses quatre vingts kilos de
ferrat
le léman a été généreux
de la générosité
aujourd'hui françois et manon vont te
aussi en avoir besoin
le jeune couple va enfin emménager au
bord du lac il ne leur manque plus
qu'une chose leurs meubles livrés
directement de bretagne par olivier le
père de manon c'était les fans et le
sécateur pour tailler les haies ça va
bien bien bonne route
ça va baser ses vignes à boé où il est
venu et et sa fille a déménagé à
emménager emménagement mais n'a pas pas
évident sa maison est remplie celle de
sa fille et je peux vous dire que ça
serment le papa de françois à mener ses
affaires
ça doit tenir à peu près dans 50 mètres
qu'à 50 centimètres carrés jeu tout le
reste c'est pour manon manque j'ai trois
enfants j'ai eu qu'une fille parce que
vérité à new delhi mobilier manon et
françois vont vite faire la connaissance
des autres locataires ils emménagent le
jour de la fête des voisins
bonjour on semblait nouveau voisin du
rez-de-chaussée envahie droite merci
nous sommes les vieux voisin qu'on va
vous débarrasser avant que vous emmener
à chier donc on vous sert un coup à
boire et puis après vous travailler mais
je pense que c'est bien mais le sieur
arrivé déjà avec un verre en main c'est
à françois roy hier matin ya ma mère ses
rivaux leur accueil
merci là mais aussi avec le livre comme
le montagnes de l'est le laki à la plage
par rapport à la résidence tu vas pietà
dix minutes à pied étaient à la plage le
tan plages superbes avec de la pelouse
et tu te mets là quand il a fait très
chaud quand tu termines de bonheur tu
vois c'est très agréable d'aller
pique-niquer ne serait-ce que le soir au
bord du lac eh bien non et les super
jérémy ne sais franchement sympa puis
talent et a pas de vis-à-vis était
tranquille quoi tu es chez toi tu est
tronquée j'en rêvais parce que bah ça
fait cinquante chandail françois et ça
fait cinq ans qu'on abat nous deviennent
mieux que terminer nos études donc
c'était évidemment compliqué n'a pas le
choix de la vie qu'on a eues mais enfin
voir notre vie à nous vrai que c'était
le ton pendant way
sacré challenge de trouver le boulot de
trouver son appart son nid douillet quoi
son nid d'amour
je les invite vivement continuer sur
cette lancée et que ma foi je suis très
fier de ma fille si si aujourd'hui mais
elle le sait mais a le poil long terme
et elle le sait j'ai totale confiance en
leur avenir
[Rires]
comment ça va merci beaucoup d'être venu
nous chercher
ouais bah et grand plaisir et puis bah
un vague offrir à quelqu'un qu'on
connaît bien belle soit votre vie oui en
plein été la température du lac avoisine
les 24 degrés
chaque année plus de 12 millions de
touristes viennent profiter de la beauté
du léman et le premier effectué avec
leurs nouveaux amis françois et manon se
lancer à la découverte du léman en canoë
kayak on pagaie en avant sont abordés
celui qui est derrière il synchronise
avec celui qui est devant tu m'oublieras
mais j'essaie d'être jamais dansé
ensemble super compliqué ok tip-top
nickel parfait regarde un sport qui
demande de la cohésion doucement en
france où tu donnes des coups de bâton
mais pourquoi tu tournes dans ce sens là
je m'arrête pas c'est toi qui tu arrêtes
de ramé
tu apprendras pas la suivante mrd eur
il a du mal depuis sai l'animal nommé
les autres gares où ils vont il regagne
la plage
là on peut pas être mieux avec mes
montagnes autour le paysage chèque on
découvre les rives d'une autre manière
c'est en se croyant en vacances manon et
françois ont succombé au charme du léman
comme martine corinne ou guy à venteuges
je pourrais pas me ailleurs qu'au bord
du lac
c'est pas possible quand je me lève le
matin fou de jouer blake roddick au bord
du lac
les gens la môle du lac c'est quelque
chose d'apaisant ya pas de mots pour
expliquer le lac
c'était bon magnifique la beauté le
calme
c'est tout sylla qui était une personne
ce sera quelqu'un de proche ça peut être
quelqu'un de ma famille après ma femme
et mes enfants des quelqu'un de ma
famille